السلام الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحم الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
الوجيز
[Silence]
‏accored
to beationutigations
of are and
[Silence]
يقول المؤلف تخليل اللحيه لحديث انس بن
مالك رضي الله عنه ان رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم كان اذا وضا
هذا الاسلوب يسمى عند العلماء
باسلوب
اسلوب التكرار
يعني اذا جاء كلمه اذا وكان في جمله يدل
على انه كان يفعل ذلك ويكرره يدل على
المداومه
كان اذا كان اذا كان مع حرف الشرط ال اذا
يقول كان اذا توضا
اخذ كفا من ماء فادخله تحت حنكه
فخلل به لحيته
وقال هكذا امرني ربي والحديث عند ابي
داوود والبيهقي في سننه
تخليل اللحيه
انس مالك
صلى الله عليه وسلم وضو
‏woulding
through the on
beard now we mention this isat this isat
the prevations
of cann be without how that تخليل اللحيه
سو
بدليل الاستقراء والتتبع
وصبر الادله
وتقعيد قواعد الفقه
العلماء
يقولون
اذا
بان الجلد
تحت الشعر وجب غسله
واذا كان الشعر شعر شعر اللحيه كثيفا
حيث لا يبدو بشره الجلد او البشره فانه
يكفي غسل الوجه
فقهاء
need
‏is enough to
face over
and
mention before another
تخليل اصابع اليدين والرجلين
تخليل اللحيه
تخليل
between
other hand
would logically assume ‏And with toes
would
narrated to use his pinky finger left
hand to work in between his toes.
اسبغ الوضوء وخلل بين الاصابع وبالغ في
الاستنشاق الا ان تكون صائما والحديث قد
سبق في فرائض الوضوء وجاء عن عبد الله بن
مسعود قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لتنهكن الاصابع بالطهور او لتنهكنها النار
و
لتنهكن كنا
النون هنا نون نون التوكيد المثقله
للدلاله على توكيد الامر قوله لتنهكن
النهال
والاستئصال
يعني ان يدخل الماء الى ما بين الاصابع
وينهك
الاصابع بالطهور حيث لا يب
شيء ما بين الاصابع او شيء من بشره اليد
او الرجل لم تصله الماء هذا هو الواجب
فاكد ذلك
between
toes
‏are they are using the exely
sparing and very easy when a person is
trying to conserve water and using a
very small amount that they will miss
something so proped
‏allcket
make
all place
wasn't they wing us we areing you
turn the fa on and this wealth of water
just kind of pours out you know and you
just stick your hand ‏there and wases
everything. This isn't how it was.
‏usually it's a very small amount of
water or if they traveling you have to
very carefully and sparingly use this
water. So if you could imagine with me
pouring some water into my hand just a
little bit and then trying to make even
if I do this three times,
if I don't really pay attention and take
my time and work the water into all I'm
going to miss something.
صلى الله عليه وسلم
تخليل الاصابع تخليل اصابع القدمين
‏into on the
between the toes between theingers is
onlyigatory
if is the only way for the to wash the
entire limb
however for instance let say water is
coming out or let say there's aam in
front of meam
‏and to
it go up over myle and take my out
and have
تخليل
to use myingers
toes
الدلك والتخليل من المستحبات ومن سنن
الوضوء
‏And they are oigat
if the if the can only be and if can
only beehend
of
the water into all those نسال
ومهوده ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا
بما علمنا وان يزيدنا علما والله اعلم صلى
صل الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
[Arabic recitation]